as so as we continue with my series on
the Marvel power hierarchy we continue
now with the remaining multiversal beans
and various cosmic entities
beginning with altes or the Living
Tribunal serves to ensure the cosmic
balance of every universe in existence
alt has is the multiversal custodian who
ensures the proper order of the
multiverse to sidetrack here where we as
the reader would assume that the various
universes of the multiverse just exists
out there and float around instead there
is an organized structure designed to
keep these various universes from simply
falling out of existence now where
Marvel and particularly writer Jim sure
are being extremely ambiguous about this
the fact remains there were altes
possesses power on par with the Living
Tribunal because his role is marginal
and that he doesn't actively participate
in the goings-on in each individual
universe
he simply remains hidden from view and
has only appeared during the 2002
six-part series the infinity abyss which
centered on his death and a new
custodian being appointed to take his
place
moving on to anthropomorphize eda
mention and manifestations this realm
exists outside of all the multiverse but
serves as a central location which can
be accessed by cosmic entities covered
in quasar number 37 from 1992 where
Marvel Comics tells us how the cosmic
entities like eternity infinity and
others are able to take on a physical
form in order to communicate with
mortals like Doctor Strange Captain
America or quasar or else take place in
cosmic battles like the Thanos
imperative or the Infinity Gauntlet
these bodies are not inherently a part
of the cosmic entities instead they
travel to the dimension of
manifestations with their given physical
forms by anthropomorphic and as a result
while Marvel doesn't give us an explicit
ranking per se on what he's capable of
the fact that anthropomorphic exists to
create bodies inhabitable why the vast
energies of the cosmic entities
indicates that at the very least he
exists on their level but in a
multiversal form having said that we
begin to move away from multiversal
constructs and begin focusing on beings
which exist within their own universe as
something I'd like you to keep in mind
is it unless it's a
otherwise your assumption should be that
each of the characters or groups in this
video going forward into future videos
have a version of themselves that exists
within each universe of the Marvel
multiverse so getting into the cosmic
abstracts these are beings that we refer
to as eternity infinity and so on now
let me point out here is that these
cosmic abstracts have their own
hierarchy from weakest to strongest but
because of the power that they possess
even the weakest of these beings have
power far beyond all earthly beings with
the exception of Franklin Richards
Magnum Josh pers and the molecule man
Owen Reese beginning with the top five
these beings are eternity infinity
oblivion death and Galactus beginning
with eternity and infinity these two are
different sides of the same coin and
that eternity represents the growth of
the universe from the time it came into
existence up until it ends and infinity
represents the passage of time within
the universe
conversely oblivion and death function
in a similar capacity and that oblivion
represents the absence of life which is
to say the time between the end of the
universe and its rebirth and death
represents her namesake in the idea of
dying
finally Galactus is actually not a
cosmic entity per se but does represent
the balance between the constant
expansion of the universe through
eternity and the death of the universe
through mistress death now something to
point out here is that while all of
these various entities and beings
mentioned in this and the rest of the
videos can be killed because mistress
death is a representation of death
itself it's almost completely and
totally impossible for her to die the
only exception to this rule that I know
of
came during the Thanos imperative
storyline when Marvel's Heroes from an
alternate reality called the cancerverse
had succeeded in destroying that
reality's version of mistress death
cutting off access to her realm leaving
everybody in that reality incapable of
dying now from here we travel into the
realm of smaller cosmic abstracts
whoever's in different facets of the
universe for example master order and
Lord chaos represent the opposing forces
of universal order and universal chaos
while these concepts represent
everything from a highly ordered
universe where all planets are the same
and the universes inhabitants all think
feel and believe the same thing to a
completely chaotic universe where the
planets have screwed up structures and
its inhabitants
without logic or reason the opposing
forces of Master / and Lord chaos exist
as balance in the form of the
in-betweener who serves to ensure the
cosmic balance of the universe following
this the entities of mistress love sire
hate entropy epiphany empathy and others
all represent the different emotional
aspects of the universe and its
inhabitants but again all of these
different entities are still wildly
powerful and dwarf the abilities of most
all of Marvel's earthbound characters -
those of Franklin Richards magic
Jasper's and the molecule man Owen Reese
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and what I
want to do here is because a lot of the
information contained in this video is
abstract because it could be very
confusing or difficult to wrap your head
around I want to open the floor and I
want you guys to start asking questions
based on things that you don't
understand and what I'll do is a next
week's video on the Marvel power
hierarchy I'll literally just turn that
into a Q&A video and what I'll do is
I'll go to the comments section and I'll
grab some of the questions that I think
are the most prominent ones are the ones
that are deserving of the most attention
and I'll basically answer those
questions as best I can to ensure that
you guys have a better understanding of
the information that we talked about in
this video but with that being said I
will catch you guys later peace
you